hey hallo hi hier ist heute packen wir
wieder ein Adventskalender aus was für
eine Überraschung
mein Gott an meinem Outfit könnt ihr
schon sehen es ist Oktoberfest Zeit
warte
diese Adventskalender hat nicht wirklich
was mit dem Oktoberfest zu tun aber es
geht um Senf und Moment hier ist ein
Lebkuchenherz das ist klassisch für
Oktoberfest sagt hallo zum Senf
Adventskalender und natürlich ist er von
senf.de wenn ihr mich und meine
Adventskalender Videos kennt dann wisst
ihr ich brauche immer so ein ganz
spezielles Thema letztes Jahr war z.B
mein Highlight der Honig Adventskalender
wo einfach nur Honig drin war und dieses
Jahr gibt's den Senf Kalender und ich
werde den sens natürlich angemessen
probieren ich habe ein Brötchen
Bratwurst Karotten und Brokkoli Brokkoli
gegessen aber ich habe ein Video das
riecht als ob es mich zum pupsen bringen
wird ich habe so ein tik tok von der Omi
gesehen da hat sie einfach ganz viele
verschiedene Sachen mit Senf gegessen
und Brokkoli und Möhre da wäre ich nicht
drauf gekommen das mal mit Senf zu
probieren aber heute ist wohl der Tag
und bevor wir das erste Türchen
aufmachen dieses Video ist nicht
gesponsert und jetzt alles dieses Videos
nicht gespannt
ich glaube aber ich habe den
Adventskalender zugeschickt bekommen
also ich bin mir gerade nicht sicher nee
ich habe ihn glaube ich nicht selber
gekauft also vielen Dank senf.de moment
mal das ist der Adventskalender
Feinschmecker mit Gewürzen Senf und
Soßen 59 Euro 90 aber es gab noch den
Adventskalender Senf und Soßen ich
wollte keine
Gewürze wir machen jetzt einfach mal auf
oder und ein Türchen Nummer eins
befindet sich wenn jetzt hier keinen
Senf drinne
das ist nicht meine erste Reaktion ich
nehme es zurück ich nehme zurück Mango
Sahne Meerrettich hervorragend zu
Wildgerichten tafelspitzkäse und
deftigen Quarkspeisen wir probieren mal
darf ich so viele Laktose zu mir nehmen
oh das möchte ich mit einer Möhre
probieren ja
richtig ist sehr scharf oder
ähm triggerwarnung ne für Leute die also
kaum Geräusche nicht ab können ich werde
kauen ich mache Gang
10 von 10 das schmeckt richtig lecker
aber das ist ja schon so die gleiche
Familie vorstellen
oh Leute was ist das für eine schöne
Stimmung draußen Türchen Nummer zwei
Brot Gewürz ich wollte Senf und Soßen
die haben gesagt willst du unseren
senfkalender ja werden senfkalender ein
Muss für brotliebhabert Brot der wird
sich darüber freuen
das riecht ein bisschen nach Anis sind
wie man sich so Lebkuchengewürz
vorstellt aber auch ein bisschen anders
in oso das riecht tatsächlich ein
bisschen so schön
so jetzt gib mir den Senf Nummer 3 lässt
sich ganz toll Öffnen der Kalender ihr
wisst das ist mir sehr wichtig mein Gott
ist das
unbefriedigend und hier hat man ein
tolles Öffnungszeiten
Nummer drei ist drin
weinzucker perfekt für Glühwein und
Punsch ich wollte Sex und Soßen
ja es ist doch toll toll ist Gewürz der
ist so ganz grob der Zucker hier ist auf
jeden Fall sehr weihnachtlich winterlich
finden wir toll Nummer vier und das ist
nicht die sind jawohl das wollen wir
doch kein Wunder denn tanisch das
gemeinsam mit geräucherten oder
gebeizten Lachs und widerstehen
irgendwie öffnen die sich so
sehr leckerer Senf toll ich würde so
gerne mal wieder Lachs essen können aber
ich kriege von geräucherten Lachs echt
Kopfschmerzen
alternative probieren wollt nimmt man
den Lachs von Rewe der mit zwei x der
schmeckt so so lecker ich habe früher
sehr viel geräucherten Lachs gegessen
ich weiß es ist
Soßen hier sind voll viele Gewürze drin
vielleicht kriege ich ja noch den Senf
und Soßen Kalender an und dann probiere
ich Senf und Soßen das ist doch auch
toll eigentlich
schön man Grill gewürzt im Winter weiß
ich nicht es ist Nikolaus und wir freuen
uns über unseren Feinschmecker
Adventskalender öffnen das letzte
Türchen hurra
oh nein es gibt zwei Möglichkeiten was
hier drin sein könnte
Beutel
du bist Senf sationell bisschen frech
das in den Feinschmecker rein zu machen
wo bis jetzt nur einmal Senf drin war
ist das noch mal so ein Schnitt in die
Wunde glaub schon heute und ich haben so
ein Thema miteinander ich finde wir
haben so viele Beutel zu Hause dass
jedes Mal wenn ich einen neuen Beutel
bekomme ich mir denke bitte nicht nein
nein nein nein oh nein lass mal sehr
positiv er stinkt nicht nach komplett
Plastik Küche Nummer 7
Burger Soße
dafür mache ich jetzt benutz mal mein
Brötchen und jetzt tippen wir mal ein
Brötchen in die Soße
das ist eine gute burgersoße für mich
gerade auf dem Burger einfach nur Senf
und Ketchup und die burgersoße schmeckt
sehr nach ähm ja mit Senf und
Meerrettich genauso muss eine burgersoße
sein dann macht man sich auf die andere
Brötchen Seite noch Ketchup und dann hat
man perfektes Zusammenspiel wie gefällt
voll gut Nummer acht Zitrone wo sind wir
hier
das ist halt einfach nur
[Musik]
sonst gar nicht aber irgendwie schmeckt
das mit Zitrone ganz lecker wie so ein
Cello
Alkohol 15%, ja gut das ist ja nicht
aber ganz cool dass sie eigentlich noch
so kleine Proben dann von etwas noch mit
rein machen was dann halt kein Senf ist
ne das ist mein problem Nummer 9 das
beste Türchen denn es ist meine
Lieblingszahl und was ist natürlich
Nummer 9 drin Senf ich spüre es hier
wird senften sein und
ich will die Sachen nicht fertig machen
ich habe es ja noch nicht mal probiert
aber es ist halt irgendwas Schatten drin
ideal als Dip zu würzigen Käse zu einem
Fleischgerichten zum Fisch und also sind
pikanten Gericht ich finde die Möhre
passt zu allem auch zu Ingwer Chutney
da bin ich ehrlich ein Kulturbanause
weil ich habe nee ich weiß es gibt ja
auch nehmen da habe ich nichts mit also
Nummer zehn
oh mein gott sieht das cool aus Limited
Edition Mutprobe extrem scharfer Senf
danger das ist der Stoff aus dem gute
Youtube Videos gemacht sind
nichts für schwache Nerven sehr scharfer
sind für alles was extra Portion Power
braucht ja beim Riechen ist schon stark
wir nehmen uns jetzt meine Bratwurst gut
rein so
[Musik]
der ist so scharf
da steht danger und ich mache hier
oh mein Gott ich liebe diesen Sender
aber geiles Design Leute die scharf
essen die haben auch so ein kleines Ego
Problem wir möchten immer wieder
beweisen wie scharf sie essen können und
wie oh das stört mich überhaupt nicht
und deswegen wenn das so danger drauf
steht und hier extrem scharf dass jedes
Ego gepusht von jedem Schaf Esser dann
sagt uh mit dem sind für dich auspassen
das ist sehr scharf und dann knallt man
sich selber so einen dicken Löffel rein
und sagt stört mich nicht ich werde
jetzt kurz mal meinen Ton Akku aufladen
weil der ist ähm und dann sehen wir uns
gleich wieder also hier gibt's jetzt
essen kann weiter geht's frisch
aufgeladen zehn hatten wir gerade
Türchen Nummer 11 Räuber hotzenplotzen
richtig großes sind 200 Milliliter wisst
ihr was für Senfgläser ich vermisse ich
weiß nicht mal von welcher Marke sie
damals waren diese Senfgläser die alle
deutschen Familien danach als Wasserglas
benutzt haben oder jetzt auf das
Geräusch
das Geräusch kommt nicht dieses beim
kindersend werde ich es mit Brokkoli
probieren erstmal so ein bisschen oh
aber schon leicht scharf
Brokkoli mit Senf nein und roher
Brokkoli auch nicht ich muss wenigstens
kurz gekocht sein probieren
das ist eine gute Bio geflügelbratwurst
das ist tatsächlich so ein Film mit
meinem Freund gerne essen weil er nicht
so scharf ist wie ich
Halbzeit Tücher Nummer 12 Gewürz Gewürz
Welt weihnachtsbutter brauner kann das
sind Orangenschalen an die Fähnchen ach
so ich vermute jetzt mal ganz stark das
ist so ein
lebkuchengeschmack auf dann mit einer
Butter und das kann ich mir sehr gut
vorstellen zu so einem schönen
weihnachtlichen Brunch das ist was was
du dann mal zeigen kannst oh was ist
denn das und dann sagst du die
weihnachtsbutter
okay habe ich gerade noch gesagt dass
ich diese Designs schön finden sind
macht scharf bei der rockigen
weihnachts-lady mit den eisblauen Augen
bleibt Dir die Spucke weg wir haben 2023
na mal gucken wie voll richtig diese
Rock Dings das ist ja nicht extrem
scharf ne
i love it schmeckt wie scharfe Bolognese
Soße
ich glaube nach diesem Video muss ich
Freunde zum Bratwurst essen einladen
damit dieser ganze Senf weggegessen wird
also noch so im Kalender hat man dann
schon ne sehr viel Senf nein doch 14
wenn man dicke Finger hat sage ich schon
mal ehrlich wird es schwierig mit diesem
Kalender
und ich kriegs kaum hin
Feigen sind Soße das ist mein jam
das muss man eigentlich zu Käse essen
ist immer aufgefallen wenn man über
Feigen spricht das jedesmal jemand in
der Runde sagt eigentlich das zeigen nur
Feigen sein können wenn deine Wespen
drin gestorben ist
fantastisch
kann ich mal so ein Senfmuseum einladen
ich möchte nicht zu so einem Wein
tasting soll ich mal so ein Senf tasting
machen 15 hey Grillkohle mehr Salz ah
okay das sieht ja krass aus nicht nach
Meersalz aus sondern kennt ihr so Deko
Zucker also für Gebäcke und Torten und
so
crazy Frau schmeckt lecker
gutes gutes Salz heißes mustha für deine
Grillparty wieder warum Grillparty wir
haben hier Dezember machen Leute im
Dezember eine Grillparty weil ich finde
ein Produkt was man dann in sechs
Monaten benutzen kann ist halt so ein
bisschen was ich mir aber damit gut
vorstellen kann ist wenn man das in sein
Salzstreuer rein macht und dann halt so
morgens mit schwarz
und als absolutes Highlight zum Ei 16
habt ihr diesen Trend von Girl Dinner
mitbekommen auf tiktok seit ich das
gesehen habe kann ich meine Abendessen
nicht mehr anders sehen als Girl Dinner
und es ist so lustig wie viele Frauen
jetzt rauskommen und sich darüber öffnen
dass wir alle eigentlich als Abendessen
nur ein paar Snacks aus dem Kühlschrank
Essen und man nie so richtig und
Abendessen hat sondern man macht sich so
ein Teller weißt du so ein Teller so
verschiedensten Sachen drauf kurze
einwandte diese ganzen Soßen und Tipps
und so erinnere mich daran Gewürz Welt
ja die absoluter Klassiker Zimt und
Zucker schon fertig gemischt ja für die
Weihnachtszeit
Kalender und jetzt habe ich jetzt Zimt
und Zucker und
Beat Drink be Mary Rad Apfel Chutney für
Desserts zu Käse und zu pikanten
Gerichten
oh tunken wir das einmal rein
Milchreis würde das so lecker schmecken
19 wir sind schon richtig in
Weihnachtsstimmung ey jetzt mal wirklich
einfach an dieser Stelle lieb euren
Support bei den Adventskalender Videos
dieses Jahr habe ich auch schon wieder
viele Leute auf der Straße angesprochen
dass sie sich so auf meiner
Adventskalender Videos Freunde
auf gar keinen Fall werde ich das
probieren das könnt ihr vergessen echter
schwarz Schnaps Likör schwarz gebrannter
oh durch seine hohe Anzahl an Kräutern
ist ein sehr kräftiger Kräuterlikör der
auch gerne nach dem Essen als
Verdauungsschnaps getrunken wird der
klassische Verdauungsschnaps man kennt
es so
lecker
haha
ich kann es nicht verstehen wie Leute
das Trinken können ohne an Hustensaft
Krankheit ich liege seit Tagen im Bett
und kann mich nicht bewegen denken zu
müssen schwarzen Schnaps wer hatte das
echt schwarz oh nein Mist wir haben 17
vergessen
original Whiskey Senf wow Senf der nach
Whisky schmeckt ist auch Alkohol drin
verfeinert mit Whisky 5% Whisky enthält
Alkohol da kommt wieder die Bratwurst
ins Spiel das sage ich euch
ja ich hatte jetzt den Kräuterschnaps
nicht vorher trinken sollen weil mein
Mund schmeckt eh nach Alkohol
extrem lecker aber kein Whisky das muss
am Kräuterlikör liegen wir sind in
unserem 20ern angekommen gut jetzt
gucken wir mal diese Gewürze sind
langweilig wollten uns essen oh shita
Glas besser gewesen zehn Gramm aber ist
auch gut dann haben sie halt probegrößen
dass man erst mal was probieren kann
bevor man davon ganz viel bestellt 21
also Leute ich wollte zwar Senf essen
aber jetzt werden wir anscheinend auch
noch betrunken Eierlikör Schoko
Schokoeier nach meinem Geschmack
oh lecker also ich dachte gerade so zu
einem Vanilleeis ist das bestimmt voll
passend aber ich bin kein Mensch der
gerne Dessert und Alkohol wenn ich ein
Dessert esse dann ist da dann soll das
nichts an Alkohol dran sein obwohl das
sogar so eine Kugel Vanilleeis bestimmt
extrem gut schmecken würde ich finde den
Eierlikör aber echt gut glaube der von
verporten das ist ja so die ähnlicher
Marke das schmeckt das immer so leicht
diese mit Zitrone und der hier das ist
okay das schmeckt eher so cremig aber
trotzdem ehrlich
22 ein Muss Raclette gewürzt was
natürlich auch toll ist das ist dann so
klein ist weil Raclette ist man einmal
im Jahr so wirklich zum Dahinschmelzen
einfach perfekt zu geschmolzen Käse das
ist ja geil schmeckt immer sehr
ungewürzt weil man halt halt ein Käse
und ein Schinken und ein Mais und dann
ist es das und ich habe jetzt noch keine
Raclette Gewürz gesehen
32 jetzt können wir die ganzen kleinen
Gläser tanzen Mango mit mir
die ganze Mango die ganze Nacht
[Musik]
verlosen seht ihr nämlich dass da hinten
das ist mein Körbchen wo ich die ganzen
Produkte rein mache in die
verlosungsboxen weil am Ende von meinen
Adventskalender auspack Videos werde ich
Adventskalender wieder befüllen und sie
dann an Euch verlosen zu kriegt ihr
natürlich alles weitere noch mit auf
meinem Instagram Kanal jetzt und jetzt
wenn dieses Video 30.000 Likes bekommt
öffne ich das 24 Türchen
schnell liken ja habt ihr alles klar im
Türchen Nummer 24 an Weihnachten dem Tag
der Tage geht man an seinen Kalender und
freut sich vielleicht schneit ich hoffe
so dass es dieses Jahr an Weihnachten
schneidet der Sommer war ja schon
eigentlich so verrückt und jetzt könnte
eigentlich der Winter auch ein bisschen
verrückt spielen und man würde dann so
ein paar Tage vollgeschneite Straßen
haben was mich immer sehr ärgert für die
Autofahrer natürlich die zu arbeiten
müssen aber ich als Fußgänger und jemand
der Öffis benutzt die dann natürlich
auch nicht fahren können Personen die
jetzt nicht wirklich an einem Ort sein
muss ich würde es liegen jawohl
weihnachtsenf was ist Weihnacht
Schärfe schmeckt besonders lecker zur
Bratwurst Wiener Bockwurst zur
Verfeinerung mit Kartoffelnudeln und
Eiersalat da packen wir unsere Bratwurst
rein
[Musik]
sehr süß
ja eigentlich schon Kartoffelsalat oder
so gehört sorry
und damit angeben wollen
Altenburger senf.de Firma Menschen ihr
könnt mir noch mal einen eigenen
senfkalender machen wo ich nur Senf drin
bekomme und wenn ihr nicht 24
verschiedene Senfsorten habt dann nimmt
einfach was von der
konkurrenzner rein löwensen der Kalender
kostet eigentlich
69,90 € zur Zeit gibt's den noch für
59,90 dieses Video ist wirklich nicht
gespannt seid der Inhalt soll einen Wert
von 85 € haben das rechnen wir jetzt mal
zusammen ein paar Sekunden später das
habe ich rausbekommen okay vielleicht
habe ich mal das ein oder andere wenn ja
habe ich mir eigentlich nur zwei
Produkte Preise raten müssen der Rest
war ja drin ich guck mal ob ich alle
genommen habe eins zwei drei vier fünf
sechs sieben acht neun zehn elf 12 13 14
15 16 17 18 19
ach so der Beute habe ich nicht
berechnet ich bin so blöd alles
mango-chutneys Gewürz habe ich aber habe
ich mir so eine Mühe gegeben mit diesem
scheiß Preise raussuchen ich sag mal so
ich glaube jetzt aber auch nicht dass
vier Produkte 35 € werden sein werden
vor allem wenn man den Beutel mit seht
ich ich kann für so ein Beutel also
eigentlich läuft man mit so einem Beutel
ja mit Werbung rum deswegen kann ich
immer nicht so wirklich also ist es
nicht so Marketing was Sie sich sparen
die packen das Marketing halt an die
Leute dann laufen sie mit einem
werbebeutel rum aber ja ich sehe nicht
wo der wurde Inhalt 85 € wert sein soll
vielleicht 65 tut mir leid wenn Firmen
mir dann auch Adventskalender schicken
ich habe an meiner Stelle bestimmt auch
Fehler gemacht aber man muss auf die
Zahlen und Fakten gucken und das ja
ansonsten kann man nichts schlechtes
über diesen Adventskalender sagen er ist
super cute diese kleinen Gläschen finde
ich sind auch toll mit den Grillkohle
Salz und was nicht alles und wenn man
wirklich einen senfan ist oder jemanden
kennt der Senf gerne ist dann ist es
eine super schöne Möglichkeit eben eine
Freude zu machen aber man entdeckt auch
neue Sachen zum Beispiel mangosane
Meerrettich kannte ich nicht kann ich in
Zukunft sagen wenn ich jemand fragt sag
mal kennst du mangosane Serie
Meerrettich dann sage ich ja aber nee
also genau das ist so das einzige der
Preis das ist wundert mich gerade und
das sagt mir auf jeden Fall dass wir das
weitermachen müssen auch in den nächsten
Videos sind nämlich schon so überlegt
vielleicht nicht mehr Ingwer Chutney
habe ich da irgendwas hat mir hatte ich
den Preis nicht rausgesucht und das
Mango Schatten vielleicht ist es so
teuer 450
€ für den Beutel man kriegt bestimmt
sein Geld da wieder raus 85 sehe ich
noch nicht ganz so aber bestimmt und
bestimmt habe ich einen großen Fehler
gemacht und das alles falsch berechnet
aber sonst ist dieser Kalender sehr
schön ich wollte einen senfkalender ich
habe ein falscher Kalender bekommen und
wir sehen uns nächste Mal wieder ja
Leute ich bin dieses Jahr das erste Mal
auf dem Oktoberfest ich freue mich
extrem darauf ich bin noch ein bisschen
ängstlich ich weiß nicht was mich
erwartet die Preise für Bier und Speisen
sind dieses Jahr erneut gestiegen wenn
ihr meine Bilder im Dirndl nicht
verpassen wollt wie gesagt folgt mir auf
Instagram gib diesem Video gerne ein
Video
ein Video nach oben gebt gerne diesem
Video einen Daumen nach oben damit könnt
ihr mich und die Adventskalender Videos
gut unterstützen und falls ihr den
Algorithmus noch so ein bisschen
anfeuern wollt schreibt gerne noch einen
Kommentar vielleicht auch mal welche
Adventskalender ihr noch dieses Jahr
gerne sehen wollt also ich habe eine
große Liste ich habe ja auch eine
E-Mail-Adresse wo man hinschicken kann
ich Adventskalender man sich wünscht und
deswegen es kommt schon viele aber falls
ihr auch so ein senfkalender ne diese
besonderen Ideen habt schreibt sie gerne
da noch rein und ansonsten schreibt mir
gerne was ihr von diesem Kalender
gehalten habt ich lese mir mal gerne die
Kommentare eure dazu durch und wir sehen
uns dann das nächste Mal wieder bis dann
tschüssikowski so ich gehe jetzt mein
Girl Dinner weiter essen ne